[Music]
on this Saturday night the number of
Kovac 19 cases climb across our country
Quebec is now the epicenter of the virus
in Canada but new signs physical
distancing is making a difference there
are sacrifices we're all making but it's
beginning to work the new restrictions
Ottawa is imposing on domestic travel
watching and waiting hundreds of
Canadians on board a coronavirus
stricken ship sit in limbo one death
every 17 minutes the alarming numbers in
New York as the u.s. struggles with
surging cases plus a famous British
inventor swaps making vacuums for
ventilators and have a group of friends
across the country is filling time with
Canada's favorite pastime
global national with Robin Gill
reporting tonight Coleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us social
distancing is making a difference in the
fight against Coppa 19 in this country
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau thanked
Canadians today for the sacrifices
they're making but he said it's no time
to get complacent here's why as of right
now more than 800 new cases have been
confirmed across the country that brings
the number of people who have tested
positive to more than 5500 more than 60
people have died that's more than the
number of lives lost during the 2003
SARS outbreak
once again Quebec saw the biggest daily
spike at 477 new cases and for more new
deaths every province and territory
except none of it has detected the virus
and as you can see the numbers are going
up right across the country Quebec
Ontario Alberta and BC are the hardest
hit the Quebec government is restricting
non-essential travel in and out of eight
regions of the province but as abigail
Beeman reports the federal government is
also putting limits on domestic travel
to curb the spread of kovat 19 we need
you to continue to stay home Justin
Trudeau is encouraged by the early
evidence out of BC that shows physical
distancing may be working but the prime
minister says people need to keep doing
it and he's tightening up on travel as
of Monday at noon people showing any
signs whatsoever of kovat 19 will be
denied boarding on all domestic flights
and intercity passenger trains it's
inconvenient but I think it's it's
necessary to slow this thing down it
makes me feel a great deal safer it's
obviously a drastic measure but it's a
difficult situation we're in it will be
up to companies to provide health checks
for all boarding passengers by asking
questions and looking for symptoms
anyone turned away can't try again for
14 days unless they provide a medical
note showing the symptoms aren't
connected to cope at 19 companies and so
on can put whatever measures in place
they're never going to be foolproof
someone can hide symptoms that's so on
you know take a Tylenol if they do have
a fever so
at the bottom line it really is I think
the collective responsibility there's
actually opportunists out there trying
to gouge the people I'm coming after
them with vengeance Ontario's premier is
talking about collective responsibility
to announcing tough fines and even jail
time for price gouge there's even a
snitch line if you're selling face masks
protective gloves cold venison hand
sanitizer and disinfecting wipes and
you're hiking the price five times ten
times what it should be you're done
you're gone that equipment is badly
needed especially personal protective
gear for those on the front lines on
Saturday the Chinese Embassy tweeted
this photo announcing a donation in gear
Canada sent supplies to China last month
the embassy tells Global News those
supplies arrived in Toronto on Friday on
Thursday the prime minister said
millions of items of gear would be
arriving in the coming days
health officials couldn't say when but
stressed to the public it should be
saved for frontline health care workers
not people who want to wear a mask while
grocery shopping
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa the
prime minister says his government is in
contact with counterparts in Panama
working on a way to help Canadians
stranded on board a cruise ship more
than 240 Canadians are passengers on
board the zaandam anchored off the coast
of Panama at least 150 passengers and
crew have become infected with kovat 19
four people have died a government
source tells global news none of the
deceased are Canadian an Ottawa area
couple on board tells global news
they're holding out hope they'll be
among the passengers transferred to
another cruise ship otherwise they may
have to wait until there's another way
home and they've started last night and
again this morning from 9 o'clock
they're moving about 60 guests per hour
and they're saying that this is the
second group and there will be a third
and maybe final group later on this
afternoon or maybe tomorrow
we're just hoping to have that letter
slide under the door the couple says
first priority to disembark was given to
passengers in windowless cabins and
those over the age of 70 in Ontario at
18 year old McDonald's employee is
facing multiple charges after she
allegedly faked a doctor's note saying
she had kovat 19 the McDonald's was
forced to shut down on Monday and send
all of its employees home to self
isolate the public was alerted and the
restaurant was sanitized by professional
cleaners police believe she was trying
to get out of work it's disgusting who
what human being would do stuff like
this we're in a crisis and they're going
out there and and lying and and putting
pepper people in jeopardy like it's
disgusting
the woman is facing charges of mischief
fraud and making and using a forged
document the federal government has
brought in a number of measures to help
flatten the curve but it's still
resisting calls to implement what it
calls its last resort well now a former
member of the Trudeau government says
it's time to bring in the Emergencies
Act Michael Cantor is hosting the West
block this week and has more on that
Mike a Colleen as provinces across the
country impose stricter measures to keep
people at home and to keep people from
gathering in groups the federal
government is firm that it is not time
to invoke the Emergencies act a prime
minister Justin Trudeau maintains that
move is not off the table but he also
says it's a last resort however a former
member of his government believes the
time to do it is now this week on the
West block retired left-handed General
Andrew Leslie applauded the federal and
provincial governments for the work that
they've done so far but he's concerned
about reports saying medical teams are
running short on supplies like masks and
ventilators he believes a federally
coordinated response is now necessary
the emergencies act I believe it's
important vitally important that it be
implemented now currently the provinces
are leading the fight
against an unseen enemy that's trying to
kill us in succeeding that fight is
gonna have to spike in intensity and of
course the time to introduce all the
measures that are available to the
federal government to provide that
national leadership in terms of
corralling the provinces and helping
them between and amongst one another is
before we get to the absolute crisis
point
Leslie believes that crisis point is
still a few weeks away and that's why he
believes the government should stop
wasting time and get ahead of this virus
Coleen my clica tour in Ottawa Mike
thank you and you can see the full
interview on the West block hosted this
week by my clica tour that's tomorrow on
global the u.s. e is now the world's
epicenter of the kovat 19 pandemic and
cases continue to multiply there tonight
there are more than 100 21,000 confirmed
cases throughout America and more than
2,000 people have died the situation in
New York is critical hospitals there are
overwhelmed and soldiers have been sent
in to help and tonight 800,000
physicians signed and sent a letter to
the American president saying social
distancing must continue in order to
save lives Jennifer Johnson has more in
hard-hit New York City a grim statistic
on Thursday and Friday Kovan 19 killed
New Yorkers at a rate of one every 17
minutes this situation so severe US
President Donald Trump is considering a
quarantine on New York New Jersey and
parts of Connecticut some people would
like to see the US Navy hospital ship
comfort will dock in New York Harbor
Monday with more beds doctors and
supplies still some New York residents
are trying to flee police are on alert
along the u.s. East Coast I feel bad
that New York is getting such a bad rap
sheet when it's really all over the
place New Yorkers coming into Rhode
Island are being stopped and registered
with the National Guard that's what I
know to be necessary
in order to keep Rhode Islanders safe
New York is still facing a severe
shortage of ventilators masts and other
essential supplies health care workers
fearing for their lives we already lost
our first nurse in New York City we're
going
lose more under an emergency order the
Pentagon is reactivating former troops
and deploying them to hard-hit regions
New Orleans Detroit Chicago and other
metropolitan areas are all facing an
overwhelming increase in kovat 19
patients doctors and hospitals across
the country are being forced to make
gut-wrenching decisions who will get a
ventilator and who will not terrifying
for patients
I felt like my lungs weren't expanding
you feel the sensation of drowning Koba
19 tests remain in short supply but the
federal government has just given
emergency approval for a rapid Kovan 19
tests with results in minutes that
enables the healthcare provider to see a
patient diagnosed a patient and take the
necessary interventions in a very short
amount of time
50,000 rapid tests a day are expected to
be produced starting next week some good
news as this virus continues its deadly
spread across America Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
in the kovat 19 pandemic past two grim
milestones in Europe today more than
20,000 people have died on the continent
after contracting the virus 10,000 of
those deaths were in Italy as dozens of
countries struggle to get a grip on the
crisis the lockdowns are expected to
become even more severe Redman Shannon
explains this is the latest two of the
Spanish government is using to try and
slow down the spread of the new
coronavirus thousands more people will
likely die so this work is all about
mitigating the misery of the coming
month
Shannon Co can Xavier mother Spanier
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez has
guaranteed full wages to all
non-essential workers who stay home over
the next two weeks on Friday Pope
Francis delivered perhaps his most
surreal mass since being elected pontiff
praying for an end to the pandemic in an
empty st. Peter's Square
a very different service in Italy's
north this church is full full Vettes of
coffins the priests opening their doors
as a makeshift morgue I started to kill
a body no one could take care of these
people said father Mario community so we
leave them here in the house of God for
him to look after them some Italians are
still not getting the message about the
importance of lockdowns
with police lecturing drivers over
unnecessary journeys
there are similar bans and public
gatherings across the continent Berlin
police controlling people's movements in
ways not seen since the days of East
Germany's Stasi secret police the scene
is no different in London where this
enormous Convention Centre will soon
open as a 4,000 bed hospital I've
developed mild symptoms of the
coronavirus Prime Minister Boris Johnson
remains isolated with the virus and like
so many he is now working from home I
think the one thing this has reminded us
is that no one is immune and that is
precisely why we asked people to follow
the government advice the British
government is scrambling to get 20,000
new ventilators in the coming weeks a
communications mix-up meant it missed
out on a chance to join a European group
purchase instead it's dealing directly
with companies like vacuum makers Dyson
and Formula One racing teams to build
the units in time to save lives Redman
Shannon Global News London
there are early indications life is
slowly returning to normal in Wuhan
China where the corona virus outbreak
began today 11 million people are
allowed to leave their homes for the
first time since the lockdown began two
months ago more than 60% of all cases in
China occurred in Wuhan but out of
concern for a possible second wave of
the virus in China movie theaters across
the country have been ordered to reclose
coming up what a difference an outbreak
can make how the pandemic is impacting
the Kinane
in real-estate landscape dropped its key
lending rate this week which led to a
drop in mortgage rates but as Robin Gill
reports the industry isn't responding
and realtors are being forced to adapt
the for sale signs may be out but most
open houses are closed welcome to this
incredible sub penthouse some realtors
are turning to virtual tours to lure
buyers
I'm only doing virtual tours of
properties that are vacant I'm not even
listing my clients properties who live
in their homes so I'm very cautious
about how I'm working in this
environment spring is usually the
busiest time to buy and sell property
now the industry is preparing for a
downturn if this all settles over the
next little bit here that summer and
fall might just be a bit busier
what a difference a virus can make
before this health crisis sales were
booming in Canada's two hottest markets
in Vancouver overall home sales in
February were up 44 point nine percent
from last year and a huge jump thirty
six point nine percent from January in
Toronto overall home sales in February
were up forty five point six percent
from a year ago and up fourteen point
eight percent compared to January we
will have a you know what we call a
recession but really it's a health
crisis economists predicted real estate
would be strong in 2020 but they're
being forced to change their forecasts
to be fewer sellers in the market if
there's also fewer buyers as well right
so you have the lower buying lower
selling activity in the market as as
household sort of sit back and buy in
many cases not by choice that's because
a job insecurity thousands of Canadians
are out of work and that uncertainty is
putting real-estate dreams on hold I
have advised my clients who do live in
their properties that this is not the
time to list even though we are in this
spring market when most people do on a
list and this is statistically the most
active time of year we are just going to
hold tight until people can start going
out of their homes and doing tours again
and in
so this is the new reality being the
looky-loo online while stuck at home
waiting to sell or buy a new home Robyn
Gill global news Vancouver still ahead
the humans on the other end of these
life-saving machines
kovat 19 primarily attacks the lungs and
many patients often have to be
ventilated to recover that not only
requires the machinery to do it but the
very specialized skills of respiratory
therapists who have to treat every case
that comes in Paul Johnson reports on
these critically important frontline
workers I would say we probably have the
most hands-on contact with the patient
meet saben Behar respiratory therapist
artis as they're known in the medical
community are some of the most important
caregivers that you may not have heard
of for a pandemic like this the moment a
patient comes into the hospital whose
presumptive positive we would be there
assessing the patient life for an RT
right now means long hours and intense
focus on safety and hygiene Behar says
he washes his hands about a hundred
times a day right now we're right at the
head of the bed right like that's the
danger zone right that that's where most
of the droplet particles are going to be
if a patient sneezes or cost
we hear a lot about the need for
ventilators which are a precious
commodity right now but the other side
of that is that people who run those
machines and those would be respiratory
therapists so the safety and security of
those healthcare practitioners is
critical right now personally this is my
opinion and the weak link is going to be
the number of our case you know how many
we can we can bring in Behar says each
RT can take care of about four or five
patients on ventilators at any given
time but since the expectation is that
each Co vid 19 patient who requires
ventilation may need it for 10 days a
surge of cases at the same time would be
a major challenge he can only promise he
and his colleagues will do their best I
want to assure the the public that you
know no matter you know how big or small
the shortage of our T's is we will get
it done Paul Johnson Global News coping
through cooking cardio and card games
popular pandemic pastimes
if you're staying home because of the
Kovach 19 pandemic you are not alone
more than one-fifth of the world's
population is stuck within the four
walls of their homes either voluntarily
or by force
regi Cecchini reports on how we're
adapting to this new but temporary way
of life behind closed doors as Kovac 19
concerns impose social distancing on
billions of people the one thing we all
have in common is time and for many it
needs to be occupied so we're all on a
journey to figure out ways to make
better use of it like joining
celebrities offering a personal dance
party or trying to lose yourself page
after page after page keeping our
routine as much as you can it's really
great isolation life has turned our
homes into a map as we try to search for
something new this is an opportunity
again for us to exhibit some patience in
a fast food and takeout world many
people have forgotten the simple art of
preparing a meal cooking is really I say
a sensual experience you taste it you
touch it and smell it you see it but
when you can connect with people you
know the experience you have around it I
think that's what's really brought
people together now it's not just
ingredients that are testing our
creative sides there's one an abstract
painting there was one on making plastic
sculptures the Vancouver Art Gallery
helping people turn their living room
into a virtual studio museums do more
than preserve the past through objects I
can we play a very important role in
shaping the future in our digital
offerings well other famous museums
bring their collections to a virtual
audience
finding child care in a world of social
distancing can also be a challenge so
kids are now learning the ups and downs
of being home more often others are
getting lost in the world of
make-believe we are probably cozied up
at home with your family library systems
like the one in Calgary offering story
time and a chance to keep students
interested in reading companies are also
taking advantage of people's free time
some putting computer science coding
classes into the palms of future coders
hands
and as the world watches the seconds
tick by waiting for some kind of good
news our homes provide us with new
opportunities to reconnect with
ourselves and our families and who knows
self-isolation
could also lead to a boom in 2033 we may
have a whole new group of teenagers
known as Generation quarantine Reggie
teeny Global News Washington that is
global national for this Saturday i'm
colleen christie tonight we leave you
with a new version of Canada's favorite
pastime call it isolation hockey a group
of friends put together this
penalty-free socially distance game
passing toilet paper from coast to coast
to coast hope it's not their last role
and hope you're finding ways to stay
connected while staying at home thanks
for watching and stay well
you